who are you
me
nobody
i just need to talk to my lawyers
this video will contain spoilers for
better call saul through season 6
episode 7 and everything else in the
breaking bad universe if you're not
caught up this is your chance to leave
okay
stuck
hey guys pete here today i wanted to
talk about why lalo showed up at kim and
jimmy's condo at the end of the
mid-season finale and what he's trying
to accomplish i don't think we can take
him at his word that he just wants to
talk his plan and fate may still be a
mystery but i think that there are a lot
of clues that we can look at to see how
he ended up ending howard and what might
come next plus that act makes things
tricky for these two scammers who will
have to come up with something to not
follow him to that carpet eventually
one of the things that made season five
so exciting was that the lawyer's story
and the cartel story finally came
together in a way they hadn't before
jimmy gets picked up by nacho who
introduces him to lalo and becomes a
friend of the cartel later when nacho
calls him up to defend his new client in
court jimmy was officially in the game
and when things went off the rails he
couldn't keep kim away from it because
they made a pact before they got married
to tell each other everything when her
husband went missing kim went to visit
mr salamanca in jail so when he showed
up at their condo looking for answers
she was essentially in just as deep as
jimmy was
she was able to talk him down to the
point he eventually left their apartment
but if you re-watch the scene this isn't
necessarily because he believed the
argument she was making in retrospect
she pointed out that he had other issues
to deal with and in the process of doing
that he made a move to shift focus where
he might be able to do something i don't
think he could say for sure that they
were lying about the bullet holes in
jimmy's car but even though something
wasn't adding up it was becoming
apparent that it might take more than
intimidation to get them to reveal the
whole story he leaves from mexico where
he finds out nacho is working against
him when his hacienda is attacked and
later realizes that nacho was the one
who introduced him to saul in the first
place gus takes precedence since he
brought violence into his house and will
always be a threat but i do think he'd
always make his way back to saul now
that nacho is off the board cockroach or
not as much as seeing that might have
made him think of jimmy i believe the
real revelation he got here was that
mike was inside the laundry waiting for
him to show up before he tipped his hand
by making the call to hector he was
under the impression that everyone
thought he was dead if you think about
the tape he was making for elatio his
goal is to expose gus to the cartel and
have them decide how to deal with him
his whole journey to germany is about
getting proof as hector rightly told him
to do when he sees mike and recognizes
that fring is expecting him he has to
look for another way to proceed he is a
wanted man who can't move freely not
entirely anyway that's gotten more
complicated now that gus is waiting for
him and he knows saul has some
connection to nacho he suspects that
jimmy was covering up what happened when
he picked up the bail money and can
piece it together that if someone told
him to do that then it's probably
related to gus
with all of that in mind it makes sense
he would go to get the truth from jimmy
that is what he's there for as far as
killing howard that is a case of being
in the wrong place at the wrong time
607's writer tom schnoz shot down the
idea that he killed him because he might
have overheard what he was saying and if
you think about it it's really not
necessary we know that lalo has no
aversion to killing and already have an
example in fred from travelwire of him
doing that to someone completely
innocent that gets in his way with
howard there's the added incentive of
scaring the hell out of jimmy and kim
and making it clear that if they don't
tell him what he wants to hear he won't
hesitate to get violent imagine a
scenario where jimmy tried to continue
the charade there's no way he would be
able to keep it up if lalo threatened
kim plus with everything else that's
going on there's really no way he could
let some random person walk out of their
apartment after the way they reacted
that brings us up to speed as far as how
we got to where the episode ended the
dead body in their living room has them
in a compromised position and jimmy
doesn't actually know enough to deliver
the proof that would satisfy the cartel
he knows about mike who saved his life
in the desert and that's basically it he
was under the impression that they moved
against lalo and took him out and now he
understands that that did not go as
planned kim has also met mike at this
point but she doesn't know much other
than the fact that he saved jimmy that
he's part of some organization that had
people following them and of course she
did know that lalo was alive but decided
not to tell her husband knowing all of
this they're gonna have to come up with
something because there's no reason for
lalo not to kill them after he feels
satisfied he's learned everything he
could from them that would be the course
of action that would make the most sense
if we didn't know saul survives to make
it out of breaking bad alive i'm really
curious to see how they make themselves
invaluable to him while managing to not
end up on the wrong side of mike and gus
when they come out on top it's going to
take drastic measures from everyone
involved that we know survives lalo is
smart he's cunning confident and
fearless he's borderline super
villain-ish and the only potential weak
spot we've seen is that he's ultra loyal
to his family all of this could work
against the character but he's got this
combination of charm that wins us over
contrasted by this super dark potential
and it all makes it impossible to look
away and he is pitted against gus fring
and mike ermentrout these are not
lightweights i saw a quote from peter
gould where he mentioned that gus's
biggest mistake with walter white was
that he underestimated him on some level
and by now they've made it abundantly
clear that he isn't making the same
mistake with lalo and of course kim and
jimmy have shown themselves to be a
formidable duo when they need to be
although to be fair they've never been
up against stakes like these this does
make it exciting to see how this plays
out howard's death was tragic but in a
lot of ways it's not the biggest problem
jimmy and kim are currently facing i'm
sure that will influence how their
stories end but i imagine there's
additional related trauma ahead trying
to get out from under lalo salamanca and
i think that is a good place to leave
things let me know in the comments how
you think things will play out and what
you're expecting lalo's next move to be
he's had this interest in mike since
their first encounters back in season 4
and i do expect him to play an important
role can lalo even let kim and jimmy out
of his sight at this point everyone at
the court knows the story about his
death and i suppose he doesn't know for
sure that jorge de guzman's cover is
blown but still i don't see him getting
careless since he knows gus is a worthy
adversary he could let jimmy go
somewhere if he was holding on to kim i
think it would be clear that he knew
that jimmy wouldn't leave her there and
i guess he could probably do the vice
versa and then wouldn't that set up a
crazy situation where she could take off
and leave jimmy holding the bag not that
i think that that would happen but boy
would that be devastating it just
occurred to me how crazy and devastating
that would be for jimmy mcgill and well
you can imagine how that might affect
him going forward please like this video
if you enjoyed it please subscribe to my
channel if you haven't already and
thanks for watching i'll talk to you
soon